[Music]
this is a candomble ritual a religion
brought to brazil by african slaves it
survived centuries of persecution and
discrimination before gaining acceptance
but as october's presidential election
approaches many of its followers feel
like they've become targets in a holy
war
a police can see hostilities increase
when you mix politics with religion our
temples have been attacked by the
growing number of radical evangelical
christians it's a battle for souls for
power and for votes
protestant christian evangelicals are
brazil's fastest growing religious group
they have become a strong force in
politics in the media
the evangelicals include president jaime
bolsonaro's wife michelle and say
they're defending the bible and
traditional family values
bolsonaro was chosen by god followers of
afro-brazilian faiths say the
evangelicals are also driving a culture
of intolerance as the election
approaches
the first lady shared this video on
social media
it shows bolsonaro's main adversary
former president
lula da silva being blessed by a
priestess
and compares him to a devil worshiper
last year brazilian authorities received
586 complaints of religious intolerance
141 more than in 2020. in nine out of
ten cases the targets were followers of
afro-brazilian religions
this woman was forced at gunpoint to
destroy her temple
edson is a condom practitioner he makes
his living as an uber driver catering
specially to people who feel oppressed
because of their faith
i know how my passengers feel because
i've been there i've had uber riders
cancel the ride when they saw me dressed
in my ceremonial clothes in the bus
people make you uncomfortable by inching
away from you
he drives fellow candomble faithful to
their ceremonies and shows them
sanctuaries like this park where they
can feel safe
until recently it was common to find
offerings to spiritual entities of the
afro-brazilian religions like this one
on the crossroads on beaches of rio de
janeiro and other urban cities this one
has food and it has perfume
and candles but every time more the
followers of these religions are going
to secluded places like this forest
because they're afraid they'll be
persecuted or that their offerings will
be destroyed
meanwhile followers of afro-brazilian
religions continue to beat their drums
and call on their saints
asking for protection and peace
monika yanakiv al jazeera rio de janeiro
let's bring in graziala tester she's a
professor for the school of public
policy and government at the dutulio
vargas foundation and she joins us via
skype from brasilia thanks very much for
being with us well why does this fear
exist in this persecution of these
afro-brazilian religions why does it
exist in brazil
yes hi laura thank you for uh for the
invite uh the
the brazilians the afro uh brazilians
have
actually been
mischaracterized as witchcraft and
related to
some things that are not true
especially by some evangelicals and some
churches in particular so we are a very
racist racist country we have this
structural racism that is a correct uh
important characteristic of our culture
and one of the parts of this racism is
the the prejudice against the
practitioners of uh um
and other religions uh related to uh
afro afro-americans that came with the
the afro-americans that came to brazil
to work as slaves so we are a country
that base it is its colonization on
slavery work and
we never had an effective policy to
include those citizens in society
uh after the slave slavery was abolished
in the late late 800s and have you
noticed this intolerance this level of
intolerance rising under jer bolsonaro
it has risen because uh minorities in
general are being mistreated and are
being uh
are not treated as they should that they
are dignity they deserve rights and they
must be protected uh jaimo sonato is
deeply related to the evangelical
community and the evangelical community
is very diverse itself it's not that
everyone
has prejudiced against uh they are for
descendants but uh jaime bolsonaro has
uh its base on those on this religion
and it has been growing because of it so
uh he's not afraid of saying bad things
and prejudice things against this
population
and brazil is still a predominantly
catholic country but we have seen this
rise in evangelicalism in politics and
in sport why does it appeal to so many
people
so
we are mostly catholics but evangelicals
tend to vote because of their religion
so they are a strong political community
as a religion
they have been rising because they uh
like 30 or 40 years ago they started
this uh this important work in the poor
areas of brazil and they uh they
actually came in places that the state
could not come and they provided
services such as uh
provide food to those didn't have food
in those places they provided some kind
of culture in places that didn't exist
and they just occupied the place that
should be uh
should be a state place and now they are
very uh a big they are strong and some
of them are centralized and they are
political related to some uh some
candidates
very interesting indeed graziella tester
thanks very much for joining us here on
al jazeera
thank you very much laura